i'm dave rubin and it's friday so we've
got another big
panel show for you guys today we'll be
focusing on big tech censorship
specifically
in the medical and legal worlds and
joining me today is
addiction medicine specialist and host
of the dr drew podcast the one and only
dr drew
stanford train internist and host of the
z-dog
md show dr zubin damania and commercial
litigation lawyer turned youtuber we're
all youtubers now viva fry
welcome to the show guys thank you very
much
thank you so i'm looking forward to this
because i think we're going to touch on
pretty much
everything that everybody's talking
about basically at every level of
society these days
related to lockdowns and censorship and
free speech and everything else
you guys have all dealt with some level
of censorship yourselves in the last
couple of weeks
drew i'll start with you is your youtube
channel still demonetized i know you
were demonetized for a while which
people think
is just about money but actually when
you get demonetized that hurts you in
the algorithm and then
you get less views and everything else
where where are you at with that and why
did i
i was in some sort of one-week d
platforming i was actually
and threatening with permanently
platforming uh for
absolute reasons i cannot determine i
was sent a list of
um policies that are not to be violated
and they were nowhere near
anything i was talking about the only
thing that came close that i could
imagine
is i had covid and i was discussing the
status as
measured of my immunity and somehow
discussing immunity is uh
touchy for for them i was talking to an
anesthesiologist who's doing research on
long haulers and we were just discussing
the controversies of
the kinds of issues that kinds of
treatments can be used to deal with
cytokine activation
deal with active viral illness deal with
brain inflammation things like
fluvoxamine that's all we were talking
about
then we get a notification that we're d
platformer we're in the doghouse for a
week and i still don't know why
right so you're in the doghouse for a
week i guess the strike from what i
understand the strike i guess has been
taken away but you know once that thing
kicks in once you're that much closer to
being gone
all together uh you you had problems
let's put youtube aside for a moment you
you had some problems with facebook in
the last couple weeks right
yeah and we're on all these platforms as
well and on facebook i suddenly got a
message on the back end in my creator
side
that said oh this uh page is at risk for
being de-published
because of violations of community
standards
and i got no such notifications had no
clue
and when you click appeal it's grayed
out so you have
no recourse and i and on top of that the
concern was
the entire page so that's a you know 2.2
million
person following thing that we've built
over 10 years
they were basically saying oh tomorrow
it could be gone with no explanation and
uh that was a little frustrating because
it had been led into
with some of my videos that were sort of
talking about the science of vaccines in
a pro-vaccine way
being labeled as potential
misinformation by independent
fact-checkers
so the whole thing was kind of this is
the thing that kills me
fact checkers go ahead i gotta tell you
this is what exercises me and and my son
is a law student got very worked up
about this
that we're we are board certified in
internal medicine
we i have 35 years of practice in
medicine i'm having a conversation with
a colleague
and non-medical professionals are
determining
what is appropriate for physician
conversation in the public sphere which
is
anathema it's bizarre and there's so
many things wrong with that i i can't
even begin to talk about
wait drew are you telling me that that
anonymous non-expert
people that work for giant big tech
companies might have some sort of bias
and should not be in charge of what
medical professionals say
right just non-medical is the part you
having non-medical personnel
determining what a physician should say
that's
a problem uh viva on the on the legal
side of this
well have you been outright censored
just because of your legal positions and
then let's
we'll dive into a little bit more on the
legal side of what people
like these two gentlemen can do so i
have not been i have not gotten a strike
i've gotten a warning which i thought
tooth and nail to have removed and it
was
more of a misunderstanding than anything
else but i did at one point when i
broke down and explained the deposition
of alex jones
that video after a couple hundred
thousand views
was suddenly demonetized and confirmed
on appeal without any without any appeal
being
lodged on my side then subsequently it
was actually removed from the platform
for violating the terms of service as
relates to hate speech
and bear in mind this was nothing more
than an analysis
of a deposition of alex jones in his
defamation lawsuit
and i didn't even include any of the
incendiary parts
so i thought that tooth and nail as well
and then magically one day it comes back
on the platform fully monetized
as though the the search terms in the
algorithm had been modified or tinkered
with
and what was taboo two weeks ago is now
green lighted once again
uh and this happens vice versa all the
time yeah and just to be clear you know
all of you guys have locals communities
you have
you have other ways that you make money
you have subscriptions and all that but
the demonetization thing i mean people
don't realize it they think oh
you're just complaining over some ad
dollars that you get but it really is
not that it then
it hurts the video's ability to get out
to other people but it's interesting
because you're talking about how
basically non-legal experts
are are shutting you down for talking
about a legal case and
and what the the two doctors here are
saying are that in essence non-medical
experts have this
kind of power drew since you've been in
the media game the longest out of us
like does any of this surprise you i
mean you've had to deal with network
sensors and all of that
but that that this has now leaked into
so much of new media as well
yeah this has gotten well i i never
expected anything like this i i
this is absolutely bizarre for me and
where it gets even more bizarre
is how much it has physicians we are
easily frightened right uh we're
frightened of liability we're frightened
of being of our reputation being damaged
in some way
and now i'm seeing doctors out in the
world
not only afraid to talk about what we
normally do which is
discuss medicine discuss controversies
discuss within the literature discuss
how we've improvised to try to help
patients
we'll not discuss it and certainly will
not try anything
and people are literally dying some of
this i think is because
medicine has become so corporatized i
really looked into this rather carefully
and
so many physicians particularly on the
general medicine side and er
are hired by large corporations or large
hospital groups
and if they step out of any alignment
with the specified clinical pathways
they are in danger so they just shut up
this is you don't need doctors anymore
why have doctors if we're not using our
judgment and not
sharing and growing and building medical
knowledge are you telling me we're not
all doctors just by signing on to webmd
and figuring out what's wrong with
ourselves
i'm just saying you have you could have
nurse practitioners do follow clinical
pathways i i mean it's what you don't
maybe that's what they intend it'll save
money i i don't i don't get it
but people are dying now in a pandemic
because people you know this is an
illness that needs to be hit early and
hard
and no one's everyone's afraid to do it
yes
yes i think one of the things that drew
pointed out is the corporatization of
medicine but the other thing is we're so
polarized now and i think these algae
these fairy algorithms that we're
complaining about
artificially censoring us you know for
reasons unclear
are the same ones that that provoke this
division in the first place because
they're preying on our
belief-based sort of human algorithms to
to divide us and that's why
misinformation spreads so fast and all
of that
it's one thing to have a a nameless
algorithm cancel you or somebody that
isn't a doctor but what you see now drew
and
and you guys is that this has bled into
the discourse
in general so on twitter and i recently
had dr vinai prasad on the show ucsf
hematologist oncologist very smart guy
very rational guy
avowed progressive his own tribe is deep
wants him deplatformed if he shows up on
my show and talks about maybe we don't
have to wear a mask forever after we get
vaccinated with
you know mutual consent they will ask me
on twitter fellow doctors
to never give him a platform and i think
it's almost like the algorithm is
getting real censorship now by humans
who
can't tolerate ideas that challenge
their
existing dogma yes
orthodoxy or nothing orthodoxy tribal
orthodoxy or nothing
and that is that is wild and scary i've
never seen anything like it yeah
and i actually want to get back to that
because this idea of follow the science
and they seem to
be telling us that if you that science
never changes or that we never seem to
learn anymore and we just have to accept
it but viva
what would you say to all of the people
watching who are saying oh
but all of you are free people you don't
have to be on these platforms there's no
reason
to complain about anything you're all
doing fine what do you say
that that may be true but the issue is
and people don't appreciate this like
you've mentioned when something gets
demonetized you don't just lose a few
bucks on the video
i've had videos that had hundreds of
thousands of views get demonetized for
no good reason
and the views go to zero so it stops
spreading the message
and it is sort of algorithmic in that
whatever the taboo words of the day are
now if you make a video even if it's an
objective breaking down of dominion
defamation lawsuits
those words trigger demonetization and
it's soft censorship you're gonna say if
i'm gonna work five or seven hours in a
day
to do something if i'm not gonna be able
to make money doing it why do it and
that's how they
deter people from discussing certain
subjects but when it comes to science
and law
people have these ideas that you know
they're settled science they're settled
law
on certain issues there is and you're
not going to have
lawyers seriously debating certain
issues any more than you're going to
have
doctors and scientists seriously
debating other issues but there's a lot
of stuff
that is not settled and there's a lot of
stuff that you get to a higher plane
through discussion and through
challenging of ideas that's right but
there is a dogma out there
there is a what's uh almost a religious
uh belief
that you can't challenge the ideas and
now it's big tech
playing the overlord saying this is what
you can and cannot discuss
and it doesn't just stifle discussion it
stifles growth it stifles innovation
and it and it divides people yeah so
that's exactly what i wanted to get to
so
so when you guys hear the phrase follow
the science or when we
when people average people see the
videos of fauchi saying masks don't work
then saying two masks then saying you
know next he'll say three masks or
you know let's not forget guys it's less
than a year ago
they told us two weeks to flatten the
curve and now they're telling us oh
maybe things won't get right till 20 22
and 100 day federal mass mandates and
everything else
that makes people very skeptical of
science in the first place and the
medical field in the first place doesn't
it drew
it's listen it's the same complaint that
you hear
whenever the press creates a headline in
science
it's a disaster what i'm supposed to not
eat eggs
i can't eat eggs what you guys can't
decide that's how science works it moves
forward when fauci said we don't want to
use mask
at that moment he was correct we were
worried that it was transmitted on the
hands
hands at the face messing with the mask
like influenza would transmit that way
and we need the ppe saved for the first
line providers
then he adjusted his priors his bayesian
reasoning
he found new information he wasn't lying
before
people want to make that lying no that
is science moving forward
and he may have a different opinion in
six months be as we learn more but if we
don't have discourse
about the about the data about our
experiences
it's certainly not going to move forward
so uh zubin is that is that sort of key
to this that everyone hears the phrase
follow the science and then when fauci
says something like drew just laid out
that
is sensible at the time but then you you
change as things happen
that people are just like ah you know
what they're all liars they're all
frauds and then of course we see all the
politicians
you know breaking all the laws and their
own edicts anyway
yeah yeah you're at the french laundry
you know talking about
wearing 12 masks and this is the thing i
think drew is spot on
that it it really is about communicating
that science is not a dogma
it's nothing settled about science
science is an approach to solving
problems and i think one of our problems
in this country is we haven't taught
people how to think freely we haven't
taught people how to do critical
thinking and how to evaluate
evidence and discussions in a rational
civil way
because our platforms and our media
don't allow us to do that when you have
such polarization in media such
polarization on social media
then that's the teaching is well there's
good people and bad people
there's right and wrong and that's it
and so when
if you're on team fouchy because of
whatever underlying belief
then then no matter what contravailing
uh evidence or discussion has had that's
evil it's not even
just that it's wrong you're bad to even
bring it up
and i think that is very poisonous to
the very scientific
basis that we're trying to espouse and
we had jay bhattacharya on the show and
he
he's been canceled a million times for
having a different intuition
on the same data on this pandemic of
course and and
listen to two things that occur to me
one is that there's no such thing as
really fact and science we just go from
hypothesis to theory
and then we test the theory over and
over again to really check its veracity
but we go from hypothesis to theory
that's it that's science that's as good
that's as close as we get to the truth
and we try to keep
you know refining that until we get
closer to the truth the other thing i've
noticed that math is dead we're not only
about teaching critical reasoning we're
not teaching
men i i had a very strange set of
questions when i got sick with covet
almost everybody asked me were you
scared were you scared and i thought i
didn't even occur to me be scared i have
a 99 probability of survival why would i
be scared
a one percent fat when i had my prostate
removed for prostate cancer the surgeon
sat down and said you have a 90
chance of cure that's a surgeon telling
me i'm cured
when it's 99 they're telling you don't
worry about it
i mean it happens but we'll tell you if
you need to worry don't worry
so it didn't even occur to me worry 99
is a good number now we don't talk about
the morbidity of this illness enough
which is fascinating to me because that
is affecting a lot of people and i'm
suffering
long-haul or stuff right now but that's
something for another day
well i mean we could do it real quick
like we know that and
get clean up the numbers the two docs
here can clean up the numbers for me but
isn't it something
like 95 or it's 99 recovery rate
unless you have two other comorbidities
usually diabetes
and overweight and that includes usually
people that are over 80. did i
ballpark that right age big thing age is
a big thing
affects people you can think of it think
of it this way dave
you know you're 36 more times likely to
die
in a car accident if you're 24 and below
than you are of covid
and but if you're over 65 you're twice
as likely to die of covet than you are
in a car accident
and people don't understand risk like
drew was saying it really is
something that we need to teach better
the math of risk and the intuition of
risk
which we've evolved to misunderstand
it's almost like we have to overestimate
risks that we
can see in our proximal or on the news
all the time which is why the news has
such a negativity bias because they prey
on that
um and underestimate like risks that are
actually much more dangerous like
driving your car
right so viva these guys these guys are
having trouble
just talking to other doctors that's one
thing right
but in terms of like lockdowns and you
know
drew and i are crazy enough to still
live in l.a where i'm still not even
sure if i can walk outside of my house
without being assassinated
although that might have more to do with
my general state of being than covent
but
um but uh in terms of lockdowns and that
that
it's become increasingly obvious that
they did not follow
science to do lockdowns we know that as
la is opening up right now we have more
cases of covid now
than when they did the the outdoor
lockdown in december
but they're finally realizing it's
politically expedient to do it
what do you think the legal answers are
because i'm a firm believer that one of
the ways we get out of this thing is we
are going to have to sue the hell out of
an awful lot of politicians
that's good for you maybe not great for
the country
well it's not good for me i'm not taking
these cases now because i think i have
enough of a public persona that i would
actually be a detriment or a liability
to a client in court
but just to go back to the fall of the
science
uh issue and it's an interesting
discussion i've been having with other
people
follow the science has turned into a
political trope for lack of a better
word where
it doesn't mean follow the science now
people are using it as in follow the
leader
and if you question it you will be shun
you'll be cancelled you'll be
brushed aside as right wing trumpism or
whatever
they've associated politics with
critical thinking
and questioning of the narrative uh and
the directions being told so follow the
science has turned into
a euphemism for follow the leader do as
you're told and don't question it
and especially in quebec our our health
director
has recently publicly stated that there
is no concrete science
to support the effectiveness of curfews
to fight the spread of a virus
says you know they're things that you
implement in wartime to prevent
nighttime
riots not to prevent the spread of the
virus and if they can't go tonight
it'll spread during the day so they say
this at the same time they're
implementing certain measures which they
admit are not
backed by science so the question is
really what do they mean by fall of the
science and
my impression now is it has been used to
divide people as to who's going to
follow the rules and be a good citizen
good citizen and who is going to
question the rules and be
a a defiant citizen but as far as as far
as how to remedy this
it takes a lot of people suing the
courts uh with legitimate lawsuits not
frivolous
lawsuits in the hopes that you get a
judge who sets a precedent in quebec
we've been somewhat lucky and somewhat
unlucky uh in the states you guys are
far more litigious and far more uh
loving of your rights
uh seemingly and far less willing to
give them up without a judicial fight
canada seems to be a little more docile
so we have not been to the courts as
much as
americans have drew this is a slight
sidebar but are we going to get rid of
newsom do you think the
the recall is going to happen i think
the recall is going to happen i just
don't know
if they're going to put somebody in his
place i mean this state is just doesn't
seem to learn anything i mean just again
i
i've been fighting the homeless thing
for two years and you i can't even
believe what i'm saying there
didn't you say something uh on
hln like maybe two years ago about the
homeless
or what was it about clinton no i'm
sorry it was about clinton's health
right that guy
hillary clinton it's a long story but i
the show had already been cancelled
and i said something about the care she
was getting not her health
the choices the doctors were making and
drudge reported that as me saying
hillary's unfit for office which was not
true my show had already been planned to
be cancelled but
and i told cnn let me go out and
straighten it all out shut up just
move along that was it uh zubin can you
talk a little bit about
since you're you're in it with a lot of
other doctors just
the level of fear that people have
because
every now and again i see i'll see a
doctor that i generally usually haven't
heard of and suddenly they'll start
getting a little traction on twitter
and i'm like oh maybe i should talk to
that person but then i have to do
some real due diligence on oh are they
just trying to go for fame are they just
trying to have their moment are they
legit
what makes them even want to get in the
game at this point because the risk is
so high and everything else
i i think that this has been a huge
opportunity for people with uh
a marginal interest in being famous or
having attention on them
to get a platform because for the first
time the average american actually cares
about the crap
that we care about uh which is all this
medical stuff like suddenly it's like
for
it thing to to to be in in medicine and
be a pundit and talk about it on
anywhere you can
and what i found is they f a lot of
these online docs fall into the same
exact tropes instead of being in what i
call the alt middle
where it's this rational way where you
can look at all the sides and just try
to process through it
using critical thinking they again take
a
tribal identifier whether it's follow
the science or whether it's you know
stay home or whether their twitter
avatar has 14
masks on it's like hi i'm dr bobby
mask your ass up jones whatever it is
that's much more
uh rewarding in terms of social media
juice
than saying you know the thing about
lockdowns is we
actually don't know if they work because
we don't we can't define what a lockdown
is it's different in every country we
haven't measured it we haven't studied
it so we have no idea whether this very
obtrusive mechanism with a lot of
economic downside is working can we talk
about that
that will get you no clicks no love no
social juice at all
and that's why i think a lot of docs
online like the most successful twitter
docs are the ones that are like
you know trump is a little [ __ ] and
it's like well that
you nailed it now you're going to get 30
000 retweets yeah do you guys
do you guys know the history of
lockdowns in the united states there's
actually a history
do you know this no go ahead it was
invented
by a 14 year old high school student in
i believe it was two
no this is this is factually true the
new york times
ran this history a high school student
in albuquerque new mexico who built a
model a computer model to reduce the
spread of influenza she determined that
you could close
locally schools down and because
influenza
is transmitted by children very
different than this virus
you can close down local schools and
reduce the spread
her father who was a computer programmer
at los alamos said that's a great idea i
bet i could build a commute a computer
model
for regional lockdowns in a pandemic the
bush administration adopted it as
policy no one had ever uh you'll not
find it in a
epidemiology textbook an infectious
disease textbook
it wasn't until the chinese communist
party
did it that it was something that anyone
thought they would ever do
and it's it's not something that's ever
been tested it's not
something that is in in the lexicon the
cdc never recommended it
it's really just something that has come
out of nowhere
without any science behind it well this
is great a 14 year old with
from albuquerque basically figured out
our whole national plan for covid
well we definitely got demonetized on
this episode i am
i have no doubt about that uh viva what
about just sort of the way
that all of this has has sort of mixed
into one thing so we covered on my show
this week
uh the time magazine article that i'm
sure you guys at least ancillarily saw
where in oh you did a nice piece on it
yeah i broke that one down
thoroughly yeah so in essence though
what they said
was this is time magazine said that a
secret cabal
of activists and other uh industries
work together to quote you know secure
the election not steal the election
security election
now i talked about it yeah to fortify
the election exactly
i talked about it on my show except the
entire time i had to keep saying
this is what time is saying not me
because youtube has given us warnings
that if we even address
any of this we'll be taken out
what do you make of that whole situation
because it's it's connected to all of
this
it will if that article if it
illustrates nothing else it illustrates
that big tech
has become a partisan player and not
anything
not even a neutral platform not even a
platform they have become
activist players in the industry with
their monopolies over
the free exchange and communication of
ideas and it's
to say it's dangerous is an
understatement people are going to read
that article
and say well everything they did was
legal when big tech
becomes the arbiter of truth and
information
uh first of all i don't think that that
should be legal in the first place but
that is just dangerous even if you think
it's legal but you know going back to
the the idea that
doctors don't feel comfortable talking
about this for fear of cancellation and
drew
i saw what happened to you you know in
the early stages of this
it's it's a vicious world in that if you
don't
toe the narrative the line the what what
big tech
and what politicians working in tandem
want you to believe
and want you to say you're going to get
raked over the coals they're going to
come after your sponsors
they're going to come after you know you
personally they're going to go after
your license
and we see it on medical issues and
we're seeing it on legal issues as in
you know lawyers by virtue of the fact
of who they represent if it's an
unpopular
opinion not only do they want you to
lose the lawsuit
they then want to come after your law
license for having dared to file an
election lawsuit or dare to represent
trump
it's tribalism in law it's tribalism in
medicine
and it's fundamentally destructive to
both yeah so to that point drew when you
when you came out and you were one of
the first people very early on that was
at least
skeptical of lockdowns um you know
obviously you see the twitter
outrage on that and everything else but
what kind of response did you get just
from
medical community and people that are in
the media world that know you
uh at the beginning yeah at the
beginning i i was just trying to reduce
the panic i was
constantly telling people which is again
when they go after you they leave out
what you actually say of course what i
kept saying is listen to the cdc
listen to fouchy do don't point at china
don't point at italy
shut up the media shouldn't have an
opinion about this this should be the
physicians and the cdc deciding what to
do
and and i i made a mistake of comparing
it with h1n1
because they're saying look we just had
a pandemic 10 years ago you don't you're
not even aware it happened
and it killed 300 000 people worldwide
you don't even know what happened
this is going to be worse but let's just
you know let's listen to our
our cdc and let's do what we're supposed
to do most physicians agreed with me at
that point but then hit pieces came out
leaving out everything i was actually
saying decontextualizing things
and i did miss how infectious this was
and this sort of non-flu-like quality
the so-called cytokine storm that we
learned about very quickly and i
apologize for that that was wrong
i missed that i updated my beliefs in
march of last year
and when fauci said it's not the flu i
adjusted my course
and have been studying it ever since and
apologized
i got it wrong i did get it wrong but i
did not get wrong
this panic that they were they were
whipping up and the fact that there
seemed to be a demand that we
follow the policies set by china which
to me was bizarre
it was just nothing that made sense to
me and to this day we're seeing
i mean one of the great misadventures of
this entire pandemic is probably going
to be school lockdowns
the massive damage that we'll have done
not to mention the overdose deaths the
mental health consequences
pushing people into poverty i mean this
will have profound consequences for a
long time to come
yeah yeah zubin do you see a sense that
to me
every system that we once knew literally
a year ago today before all the lockdown
started
every single system is either going to
crumble
or be basically completely
unrecognizable at this point
a thousand percent drew you know when
you were saying all that stuff you have
a major media platform and i have this
weird gorilla thing with a lot of
healthcare professionals and
i was saying the same [ __ ] loudly about
the panic the
fear porn that was everywhere and the
fact that we were going to hurt kids we
were going to hurt the economy we're
going to cause
depression alcoholism suicide substance
abuse and what's interesting is i could
say that without cancellation in the
early days because it hadn't tribalized
enough yet
and what was happening is i was getting
this feedback from
physicians who were saying you know
you're saying all the stuff that we
think right now yeah because we've seen
we've been through h1n1 we know this
isn't flu but this is also not
the plague it's not something with a 90
fatality that's aerosolized in all of
this
and and the school piece was big so dave
to your question
the idea that our systems have uh
completely flubbed this i think
this is the first time we've had a
pandemic in the age of social media and
cable news
in the age of such political
tribalization and now we're seeing what
happens
hopefully that'll wake us up to
understand that this is not how you have
dialogue do science move forward
and actually prevent the most harm for
the most people which should be our goal
in the first place
as a guy that cares about uh the law a
little bit are you shocked to see how
quickly we all just kind of rolled over
i i'm going to florida in a couple days
and i'm looking forward to a little
freedom
i have been accused that the doctors
will know what this is i've been accused
of having
odd oppositional defiance disorder i was
i was stubborn as a kid i'm still
stubborn
perfect attorney well yeah that's right
no the degree and the rapidity with
which people have just
said okay i'll accept a curfew i will
accept
the violation of our most fundamental
civil rights and liberties
in the absence of you know the most
compelling needs to
infringe on them and in in the presence
of the most minimalist infringement to
begin with
i'm i am shocked uh i'm surprised i'm a
little disheartened because
it took people's lives and decades to
fight for those freedoms
and now the government knows that it can
get away with
imposing a curfew notwithstanding its
own admitted absence of scientific basis
to do it
um i don't know how it comes back and i
don't know how long it takes to come
back if it ever does come back but
i was i've been shocked but one thing
i've been sort of encouraged about
is i have a lot of discussions with
people privately and i suspect
dr drew and dr z dog you have the same
thing a lot of people privately
agree it's just that they don't want to
say it publicly because
of the power of social media the power
of big tech to
shun and destroy anybody who publicly
voices what a lot of people believe
uh quietly and will emit amongst
themselves yeah so my audience
dave i'm hoping that locals is our our
quiet home where we can stream and
communicate and uh you know meet with
people
and have control over the the content
and the platform
i mean that's literally why we built the
thing and what you do i mean i know this
sounds so crazy but drew what you do in
your locals community it's up to you
it has nothing to do with me isn't that
isn't that bananas i
believe that you can create will i have
to shelter in place while i do it
but but i don't want to well that's not
what i'm thinking that you guys are all
on there right because you're all
you're all masters at your own craft and
you want to have
a place to communicate with your own
people that that is not beholden
to a bunch of non-experts to tell the
experts what to do zubin go ahead i can
tell you got something
so for the locals thing it's the first
social media it's not even social media
the first
community platform that i found where i
set the tone
like i say listen we're going to be all
middle we're going to be rational we'll
be respectful of all dialogue
and nothing is off limits but if you
know you'll see if it's not resonating
with people
and it actually happens because the
tribe
that's built there actually takes that
seriously whereas they're
on facebook on youtube they're
incentivized to hurt each other
it's all sport and theater and and it's
really great to have that
well well i like the idea of a radical
middle i'm i'm because the both ends
look crazy when you stand in the radical
middle
and dave the radical middle meaning that
you're okay with some people
disagreeing with you every now and again
how radical we have all become welcome
yeah go ahead viva i was gonna say i i
have to i we have
a uh a local page as well with robert
barnes
where you know we have our call it
radical middle for lack of a better word
and i don't want to make anybody nervous
but
it is only going to be a matter of time
this was something i warned uh or i
discussed with the ceo of
of um rumble during our live stream and
it's something that we now saw with
parlor
and i think dan bongino also talked
about it you know having a dual economy
it's going to get so bad or it could get
so bad where big tech is going to go
after not just the platforms
but the isps the not just the payment
processing but the banks themselves
and so you say something i i am
concerned that it's going to come to the
point where
even on your own private communities the
war will be waged
in ways that are just going to go one
level up but as far as it goes
yeah you know the ability to ex post
posts and express your ideas
without having to play with your words
so that it doesn't get flagged and it
doesn't damage the channel that you've
been building for five years
it's a great thing yeah and by the way
i'm not gonna sit here and lie to you
we have not solved all of the
technological stuff yet we have some
redundancies with servers and there's
some other things because we as you guys
know
we have paid communities that keeps out
99.9
of the bad actors and we have i think a
very solid terms of service but
yes can they do all of the horrible
things
that we can think of and some things we
can't think of there's just no doubt
the answer is yes but uh before we wrap
guys i i try to always end these shows
with some kind of silver lining because
i just know so many people
drew you hit on this a little bit and
you did too as well as zubin this this
idea that people really are depressed
right now i think especially young
people they don't see a future
um i can only imagine if i was 20 what i
would
think the world could possibly be like
everyone just thinks there's
there's a real nihilist feeling and
everything else right now can you guys
paint something that that feels kind of
all right
drew you've been doing this forever to
try to get people out of these dark
places
yeah uh i i don't have any great uh
enthusiasm
uh i do think the economy is going to
recover i do think there will be jobs
i think it could get overheated but
that's going to be an issue that we'll
have to deal with down the line
i think people with opinions
fundamentally should
hold their head up they should
understand if they're just trying to do
good and share ideas and help other
people
hold your head up put one foot in front
of the other and keep
talking uh there are always people that
are they're increasingly people that
want to try to struggle with the truth
i think one of the silver linings is an
awareness that things are tribal and
awareness
that that things are so siloed
that you can't trust anything i've
particularly seen this
in uh sort of under 18 where they're
trying to
figure out how they assess news how do
they determine what is good sources and
what art
be a good source and uh just keep moving
forward
and hopefully i have tremendous faith in
the american system
things will write itself yeah zubin
i i think human evolution is beautiful
it's inevitable and it's
inevitably messy so we're going through
this phase where we're getting better
but in the process we're seeing the
shadow of some of this
stuff that we're pulling along this sort
of human baggage that we have that
gets weaponized through new technology
that we don't fully understand yet and
these algorithms and the business
incentives that go with it
and i think once this pandemic is going
to shine a light on it it's going to
transform medicine because already
telehealth
non-in-person encounters and the way we
pay for medicine will be transformed i'm
actually as optimistic as i've ever been
that as we get to the end of this
with what drew said that meta awareness
of
how we think and how we think critically
that will transform and
emerge the next sort of stage in our
development so i'm excited
viva dr free uh dr z just gave me i just
called you a doctor
uh dr z just gave us some uh some
positive vibes to go out on you can you
top that
uh i'm not sure i can top it all i can
do is repeat something that robert
barnes
often says when i ask him to motivate
our crowd he says
you can't control what happens to you
you can only control the way you react
to it
um that we live in a world of tribalism
now where
the powers that be and i will call them
social media big tech
incentivizes radicalizing of people they
i believe
specifically go to their way to try to
further radicalize people
through de-platforming through
alienating through ostracizing
my only word of advice and my only
optimism is
do not let the system radicalize you
because when they do radicalize you then
the system is won
so stay sane and stay open and stay open
to having dialogue
and avoid demonizing people who have
ideological differences
because that is what twitter youtube
facebook wants everyone to react like
and that is the force that we have to
resist yeah i'm trying man i know you
guys are too it ain't easy sometimes
especially these days and
and the way the algo algorithms are are
tricking us well listen you know as
as all of the big things sort of crumble
around us uh i do think that the bottom
up internet is the right way so i'm
thrilled that the three of you guys
are on locals doing your own thing we're
gonna link to your locals
communities down below and you know the
other part of this is that networks in a
traditional sense you know drew you're
you
you came from the network side of this
those things with the giant overhead and
the huge studios and all that stuff it
is not necessary anymore
i got two guys in my room that's it and
uh
we're building new networks and i and i
think this is part of it so i'm thrilled
to be in the game with you guys so i
thank you very much for joining me
thank you very much dave thanks dave all
right
thanks to dr z dr drew and i almost
called him
dr viva dr f oh he's not a doctor he's a
lawyer uh
guys these these people are all on
locals it has nothing
to do with me other than i started this
thing so i would encourage you
to check out what we built and of course
you can check out the reuben report
community at rubinreport.locals.com
we've got to figure out some stuff and i
think we have a small window
to do it like the longer that we we
don't
solve these problems whether it's
talking about lockdowns honestly talking
about cove
honestly talking about our political
polarization honestly like the longer we
don't solve these things
and of course the big tech censorship
part of it it's like these things will
only get worse and then one day we're
going to wake up and we won't even be
able to sign on to these things i mean
imagine if big tech
tomorrow just said hey we're just taking
half of you guys out you know we're
we're
we're shutting down the droid army now
that we won the war you thought i could
do a whole show without a star wars
reference
um i think i think it could all happen
so fight back however you can i actually
thought that all of their advice
at the end was was quite right that we
we will be okay one way or another but
it's on us anyway thanks for watching
guys uh get offline for the weekend how
about that
i'm gonna do that i'll be in florida so
see ya